hi I'm Garrett Ruhlman a professional
educator our studio and the author of
two books on our I've put together these
videos to teach you some of the main
ideas of doing data wrangling with our
and the tidy verse if you're not
familiar with the tidy verse it's a
collection of our packages that are
designed to help you do data science in
this series of short videos we will walk
through some of the most useful tools
for wrangling your data with the are
also keep in mind that you can skip
around these videos to the tool that you
want by clicking the jump to links in
the video description
normally when you angle your data you
have two goals first you might need to
make your data set suitable to a
particular piece of software for example
we're going to need to make our data
suit we'll talk our because that's what
we're using and then second you can
actually reveal information by changing
the format and the structure of your
data let's start with this first goal
making our data suitable for our so your
data sets can come in many different
formats but there's one that are
definitely prefers more than the others
and I have some toy data sets in this
package which I've built on github you
can download it if you want to use these
data sets it's completely not necessary
I'll be using these and you can just sit
back and watch but should you want to
install this package first install the
dev tools package which is on crayon and
then use the installed github command in
dev tools to install this from the link
our studio - Edie aw are inside this
data frame my inside this package I have
some data frames that are all fairly
small but demonstrate the sort of layout
and formatting issues that you might
encounter it with data in our example
here are three data frames from the
package one some data about hurricanes
in the Atlantic Ocean one some cases of
a disease in this case TB in different
countries in different years now once
some data about pollution and we can go
through these three data frames and try
to analyze what they contain in
particular we could look at what
variables are in each of the data frames
so in the storms data frame is pretty
straightforward we have a variable that
talks about the names of each of our
storms
variable as something to the wind it's
actually the maximum wind speed recorded
for each storm a variable that records
the pressure of each storm and the date
on which these measurements are made so
there's four variables in that data
frame if we turn our attention to the
cases data frame we'll see that we have
a variable that has some sort of country
code so we see France H land in the
United States there we have a variable
that lists different years 2011 2012
2013 and we have a variable that's left
over that's something like a frequency
or a count or you might just call it n
that's here and if you compare cases the
storms you can see already that we have
a difference between the two data frames
they store the values of their variables
in different ways and storms each
variable is put in some one column in
cases one variables in a field of cells
once across the column headers and ones
in its own column when we get to
pollution we see any different formats
still we have a variable that's
different city names and then it looks
like we have a variable that describes
particle size and variable it describes
some sort of amount but I think you can
also argue and this is what I would
argue that we actually have a variable
which is the amount of large particles
that each of these cities has and its
air and the second variable which is the
amount of small particles that each city
has in its air and if you wanted to
compute some number for each city like
the ratio of large to small particles
then you'd have to treat these things as
separate variables to do math with them
so we can look at this data frame as
having three variables that are
structured in a different way so this is
what I mean by data sets come in many
different formats but if you looked at
how you'd pull the values of these
different variables out of these data
frames you'll see that one of these
formats is much nicer with our code than
others in the storms data frame you pull
out each variable using the same syntax
the name of the data frame with dollar
sign the name of the column that you
want but if you want to pull out the
value so say da the count variable from
cases you'd actually have to extract a
bunch of cells and paste them together
in some way we
the names of the columns blow them
together when you move to pollution you
have to do something similar and this is
bad because when you write your code you
want to be able to make it as
generalizable and as automated as
possible and if you have to stop and
look at the data set that you're working
with and then think about how to extract
the values of the variable you want
within that data set
well this could be really hard to write
a piece of code that will work with
other data sets as well the chance for
making an error would be much greater
so just due to the way our works its
syntax structure and everything it's
much easier to work with your data if
each variable is on its own call but
there's other advantages as well if we
look at the storms data frame and
consider making some sort of new
variable in this case the ratio of
pressure to wind meteor logically I
don't think that's a meaningful variable
but this is similar to things you do
with your own data you'd use some math
like this and our and what that code
would do is it first extract the
pressure variable storms and then it
would extract the wind variable and it
divided the - and the way our operates
is is it's go to element wise operations
so instead of doing some sort of linear
algebra thing here you just go pair up
the first value of each vector the
second value third thoughts so on and
within those those elements I'll do the
task of division and so we get a vector
that has at the end just as many values
as the original vectors now this is
great if you put your data in such a way
that each variables in its own column
and then each row contains a single
observation because what element Y is
operations would do is it'll make sure
that the values of one observation are
only paired with other values from the
same observation which is a day
scientist is just what you want we
wouldn't want to divide the pressure of
Alberto by the wind speed of Alex that's
really not a meaning for the quantity so
we want to make sure we keep the
pressure of Alberto with the wind of
Alberto and the pressure of Alex with
the wind of Alex and so on well the
structure of the storms data frame makes
that happen automatically
it's taking advantage of ours Elmen wise
operations so that's what we round about
way to say that there's one structure
that just works well with the natural
quirks of our and if you put your data
into that structure before you begin to
analyze your data
have a much quicker more efficient
experience when you work with that data
and I'm gonna call that data structure
tidy data this is a term invented by or
popularized by Hadley the author of Tidy
R&D plier and what it amounts to is you
take your data make sure that each
variable is saved in its own column
which we saw storms did make sure each
observation is saved in its own row not
going to go into what an observation is
here but it
obvious and puzzling at the same time
and then finally you want to put
basically all the data that you plan to
work with in the same data table before
you start working with it otherwise
we'll be recombining your data every
time you make some sort of adjustment to
it so if you make your data tidy with
variables and columns observations and
rows and the type of data in its own
table they'll be easy to access your
variables and you'll automatically
preserve observations as you do things
to your data so that's sort of the goal
tied yaar is the means to get there
it's a package that picks up where
reshape to left off if you are a user of
reshape or reshape to and tidier has two
main functions gather and spread that do
similar things as cast and melt if
you're coming from the reshape world and
then there's several other functions
will look at in there but these are the
main ones and let's take a peek at them
so this is the cases data frame this is
how the variables were distributed what
I'd like you to do and just for 30
seconds because I can't really check in
with you guys or communicate with you
imagine how this data frame would look
like if you restructured it to be
similar to storms if it was tidy and had
the variables country year and end I
think if you try to scribble this out on
a sheet of paper or something it'd make
it much easier to follow what gather
does which we'll look at in a second
all right so hopefully you had a chance
of man
what this data would look like in a
different format and this is what I
proposed this days that would look like
in a tidy format we want to keep all of
the information in the data set and we
want to keep the variables are there and
the values are there we just want to
restructure them so the variables each
appear in their own column and we know
that the columns we want to end up with
are something like country year and the
N and we can also look at the old days
that they turn what values need to go in
which rows of the new data set we need
to have some combination of France the
year 2011 and with this end value for
that combination needs to be 7000 we
also need a combination of you know
Germany in 2011 with its own value and
basically we need to pour it over all of
the values in this field of cells into
our new data frame but when we're done
our data frame will look like this so
this is a tidy version version of the
cases data frame now it's very easy to
pull out each of these variables by
selecting the column name and we can do
this sort of thing with the gather
function and before we do it we want to
develop one piece of vocabulary so if
you look at the output you see it
basically took the right-hand side of
this data frame and turn it into two
columns the first column is a key column
these are the names that these cells had
in the the previous data frame the
column names and we'll call the second
column of value column so these are
actual values that appeared in that
field of cells and any of the key value
pair is actually pretty common so we're
gonna use gather to take a cells and
turn it into just two columns a key
column and a value call this is how the
function works this function comes with
the tidy our library and you first get
it the name with the data frame that you
want to clean up and then you give it
the name that you want to use for the
key column that results in the name that
you'll use for the value column so we
happen to be moving column names that
were years into its own key column and
cell values that were you know n for
frequency into their own column column
go out to you know gather and tidier
can't
what those things actually stand for so
here we get to tell them what's the name
then you call us then finally we just
tell gathered which of the columns we
wanted to use when it builds those final
two columns you may remember in the
cases data frame the first column is
already tidy the countries were already
in their own column so we don't include
one in this index here we leave one B we
just included two through four those
were the columns that's we're not tidy
when you do this your data will go from
here to there so at this point if you
downloaded the elements called Eid or
package you could load it and you'll see
that you know the storms data sets in
there the cases data sets in there
actually all the data sets on my cheat
sheet err in there and all day sense
we'll go over today and so if I took the
code here can run an R and verify that
gather comes from tidy other tidy our
library all right now you can see that
we're going from our rectangular data
frame our table to our tidy data frame
here so I'm I know there'll be a lot of
functions go through but let's go keep
pushing forward because you 45 minutes
isn't that long time okay so this is our
pollutions data set and it has three
variables distribute like this we can
make this data set tidy with the column
called City of Concord large from Colin
called small before we do try to picture
in your mind what that would look like
which will help you understand the goal
we're working towards in the next few
slides
so the cases dataframe looked like
rectangular data that's the sort of data
that you'll find very often and you only
have a few variables and you want
display in and a format that fits in a
paper very well I don't know what to
call this sort of data but it exists
quite often as well and if you can
switch this sort data and rectangular
data you pretty much have full control
over and format your data frame so
here's the pollution de set as it is and
we want to make it a data frame that has
these columns in it and just like before
it's only a matter of retraining the
combinations that appear in the original
data frame in our new data frame and
when we do that this is what the result
looks like see it's tidy it's more
rectangular than the previous data frame
there's fewer rows we've removed some
redundancy here basically we've made
something that looks more like the cases
data frame from before when we did the
operation Regan we're working you could
think of it as working with the key
column and about you column the
operation that we're going to the
function that does this operation is
called spread and what it does is it
looks at the original data set and you
give it a column to use as a key column
and a column uses a value column and
they'll use those columns to recreate a
field of cells but the way you call
spread is the idea would be that the
field of cells to recreate will be a
tidy field of cells
the syntax for spread is you give it the
data frame you want to reshape you give
it the name of the column use as a key
column in the original data and the name
of the column you uses the value column
in the original data here that size and
amount and then it makes a transition
for you
you can think of spread as taking data
that's in a key value column format and
putting into a field of cells format or
rectangular table format whatever Cabul
air you like you can think of gatherers
doing the opposite and by going back and
forth between gather and spread you
could actually move values into call
names out of column names variables into
rectangular format a tidy format and
since you don't have to apply spread or
to apply gather to the same columns each
time just by iterating between these two
functions you can take the same data
preserve all the combinations in the
data and make the layout very very
different than it was to begin so the
tinier package also has two other
functions I think are useful but not
always going to be that useful if you
looked at the storms data set and you're
very persnickety you might notice that
actually has three more variables in
there you could extract a year variable
from the day a month variable in a day
variable and those variables are all
combined into one column here the date
column what separate does is it takes a
single column and it splits it up into
multiple columns based on some sort of
separating character so this is really
easy with dates because dates normally
have some sort separator between the
year month okay and if we ran this code
above here we get a new data frame where
the date column has been split into a
year on the day three columns
if I save that as storms - then I could
use unite which does the inverse it
takes several columns and puts them
together in the same column adding a
separator between the values of the
previous columns so that's a great way
to recreate some dates although in this
case those dates would be character
strings you need to reparse them if you
want them to behave as dates in our
that's another story
so just to recap about the tie our
package is Tamiya primarily works with
the layout of your data entry shapes the
layout use the gather function in the
spread function to change the shapes
back and forth they're complementary and
then you can use separate and unite to
split up in unite columns they're also
complementary this this package is
designed basically to get data into that
tidy format which is the most efficient
way to work with it in our thanks for
checking out our data wrangling video
series this is just one video in a
larger set of resources on data
wrangling so here are links to all of
our other videos in the series and again
have a look at the video description for
shortcuts to other parts of the series
as well as other resources we think
might be helpful like cheat sheets and
further documentation we hope you find
all of these resources useful and if you
do as always we would appreciate a
thumbs up or a share both go a long way
to helping this content reach people who
could benefit from it